so i'm curious were you able to see the
movie top gun and if you did watch it
did you like it did you watch it by
yourself why do i ask well i watched the
movie top gun with a couple of my
friends
and if i would have gone by myself i
probably would have only seen it from
three or four or five different angles
but when you watch top gun or a great
movie with multiple peers
you see things that you couldn't see by
yourself the same as going to business
conferences i've gone to many business
conferences in my lifetime when i go by
myself and i'll say yeah that speaker
said this
and i learned this and i learned that
and i learned how to raise money like
this or start the podcast like this or
do this like this
but then when i go with other people
they said yeah but remember when he said
you also have to do the six steps of
this oh i didn't catch that yeah at this
point oh wow that's pretty interesting
what's the point here just the same way
we don't go to concerts by ourselves we
don't go to movies by ourselves and many
of us don't go to dinner by ourselves
you do not want to go to a business
conference by yourself this is a special
offer we're running for 20 off for those
who buy three tickets or more meaning
bring your business partner bring your
sales leaders bring your best sales
people bring your best employees bring
your best managers that you have with
you at the vault conference or even your
peers that all have big visions as well
because when you leave and you debrief
every night at the hotel room you're
going to have a certain lens you're
going to see that you can do it by
yourself so if you haven't registered
for the vault yet don't buy one ticket
don't buy two bring your entire team get
a 20 discount click on the link above or
below i'll see you in miami first week
of september take care everybody